deux sites
[Applaudissements]
alors on va commencer avec un gala le
gala du met du métier très mondain le
connaît par coeur il est où ce gala du
met c'est à new york en lorraine mais
c'est pour une bonne cause c'est pour le
sait la ses commandes le département en
costume du mma du metropolitan museum
art enfin
opéra de new york non
c'est pas le moment non plus on s'en
fout et
attention on est poli talent musée art
de date leur bien et chaque année toutes
les plus grandes stars défilent dans des
tenues incroyables puisque l'idée c'est
d'avoir des costumes extravagants et
cette année encore ils ont bien réussi
alors sachant que l'année dernière ça a
été annulé il vous a fait un petit récap
pour bien comprendre ce qu'est ce gala
incroyable
lundi se déroulait à new york un
événement annuel véritable référence
dans le petit monde de la mode le maître
gala damn à carling le but de cette
cérémonie est simple rendre hommage à la
haute couture et la culture américaine
l'occasion pour les stars du monde
entier de se vêtir de leur plus bel
habit de lumière quitte à nous éblouir
un peu comme timothée challamel au
maître de cérémonie qui avait décidé de
se déguiser en stormtrooper de star wars
pour l'occasion
[Musique]
pour une fois kim kardashian n'avait pas
sorti son meilleur décolleté elle a même
choisi de tout cacher avec cette tenue
de belphégor des plus angoissantes
est décidément la saison n'était pas la
couleur puisque rihanna de son côté a
fait le choix de venir sur le tapis
rouge avec sa couette tout noir d'autres
préfèrent adopter la tendance chewbacca
comme la fille de madonna lourdes leon
s'est affiché avec une tenue au poil
bref rien de surprenant cette année sur
le tapis du maître galère quand on a
l'habitude d'avoir chaque jour sur notre
plateau guillaume genton
alors quand même tout net ou n'est pas
très beau alors je ne connais pas en
mode mais certains trucs sont très moche
quand même la grosse doudoune de rien
elle est marrante et c'est d'ailleurs
ballan gaga à la femme elle marque voilà
une très belle marque qu effectivement
c'est une marque on va souhaiter qui
habille également et salons gémeaux est
beau et du jus par hiaumet couilles et
alors
concernant les looks vous delphine
quitter votre look préféré de ce gars là
ô combien passionnant
des saxons j'ai bien et mick kelly
jenner kendall kendall
et la vie oui quel kendall août alors
que kane alors pour le coup c'est pas
très extravagant mais on va discuter si
vous sentez pendant leur
tapis pour un tapis rouge je sais
quelque chose me dit papa piscine
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tapissez canada génère cette très jolie
pour une montée ou l'api par exemple
pour un festival ça c'est pas très
extravagant tout le monde peut porter ça
c'est pas très étonnant je ne sais pas
mais extravagant
transparent chez vous non mais moi sans
hésitation c'est kim kardashian elle a
frappé très fort là moi c'est une belle
figure
la même marque que rihanna et je trouve
que justement alors si vous voulez en
fait tu le mets de gala c'est le moment
où toutes les filles sortent leurs plus
belles robes leurs plus belles parures
et que c'est un axe tard sauf qu'il ya
un thème chaque année hélas le thème
c'était les états unis donc elle qu'elle
s'est dit bon ok comment résumer états
unis elle a résumé avec le t-shirt donc
ans habillés en tee shirt de la tête aux
pieds et surtout ce qui est vachement
génial je trouve en tout cas sosh manger
manger donc se cache en fait une espèce
de performance artistique c'est à dire
que kim kardashian on l'attend à poil et
là étaient couvertes mais moi j'ai des
traits mais fut à deux
doigts si vous voulez c'est la
surenchère le mets toi c'est à dire que
les oscars à côté c'est le seul à
publier de ma petite cousine auriez
c'est ça on m'a demandé à gilles qui est
un expert en vêtements en jambes rihanna
mais on touche au sublime avec rihanna
on la veut loi rien c'est la rue beauté
féminine avec l'incarnation de la beauté
des tissus de la soie l'état on dit
[Rires]
c'est la joconde réincarner riadh
ben dis donc eh ben dis donc
j'ai vraiment une vie de merde
je connaissais pas mais tu sais pouvoir
des gens habillés dans des dents dans
des sacs de couchage
je ne connais pas
guillaume genton bas au delà des jeux
rappelle que nous bougeons expert en
mode et en esthétique évidemment soin
esthétique du visage évidemment et 11
est très beau aujourd'hui vers cerveau
si elle est certainement c'est parce que
vous avez rendez vous avec x non c'était
pas prévu
voilà ce que je suis je suis très déçu
de pas avoir été invitée évidemment mais
ce que j'ai aimé c'est qu'il ya eu des
tenues très engagé dans one drop avec
marc et taxer les riches par exemple il
y avait une autre robe de fins et c'est
dur pour vous ça m'a vraiment ça
megan rapinoe qui était qui soutenaient
les homosexuels et je trouve que c'est
bien à bord des thoniers engagé que
c'était pas que voilà de 2,2 du vide et
de la forme il ya aussi un peu de fond
c'est conceptuels comme des sectes à la
langue et à la table bon écoute et on va
suivre tout ça de près oui mais
prochaine maintenant mais forcément
besoin évidemment informés à ce fameux
sujet j'en ai parlé il ya un instant
c'est évidemment la sphère qui a
bouleversé tout le monde madame de
fontenay alors elle est têtue pendant un
temps je pensais qu'on était tranquille
et ben non elle est ressortie de sa
tanière pour s'attaquer à une fois de
plus
alors évidemment en plus elle s'attaque
sur un truc qui commence samedi peu à
dater je me rappelle plus de la date
d'élections
où 85 des 180 et elle refait d'une
polémique en venant nous expliquer
quelques années après qu'en fait les
élections élections étaient truquées
donc on lui en veut pas parce que bon
c'est madame de fontenay puis elle a un
chapeau sur la tête donc voilà
on vous a fait un petit récap et ensuite
on vous explique sue est honteux
défendra en visio à nathalie marquer
regardez
[Musique]
qu'on se le dise il ya bien une hache de
guerre qui ne sera jamais intéressé
celle entre geneviève de fontenay et
nathalie marquay-pernaut geneviève
arrêtez de nous casser les couilles
élue miss france en 1987 7 qui a été sa
chaperonne trouve depuis des années que
nathalie n'honore pas l'écharpé de miss
en raison de son comportement trop
vulgaire à son goût ce qu'elle n'a pas
manqué de rappeler lors d'une interview
dans l'instant de luxe j'ai jamais
compris ce qui lui est passé par la tête
quand elle a commencé à parler de coup
et tout ça deux trucs une guerre ça vous
a pris mais cette fois-ci geneviève ne
s'est pas contenté de critiquer les
manières de son ancien disciple la dame
au chapeau n'a pas hésité à insinuer que
nathalie marquay n'aurait jamais dû
remporter la couronne de mise dénonçant
un énorme cafouillage celui qui criait
europe tu sais il s'en sortait pas des
bulletins et tout ça est donc d être
finie elle affine ça finit bien par
l'alsace pour lui où il pensait que
c'était une miss réunion vous avez
trouvé ça bizarre bah oui la reine des
miss n'a pas mâché ses mots en
n'hésitant pas à parler de trucage tout
le monde est étonné bah oui j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup ont été bons
c'est jamais sorti sa
gestion c'était la première élection
télévisée ouais alors ils n'ont pas
voulu faire d'une histoire le moins que
l'on puisse dire c'est qu'à 89 ans
geneviève à la rancoeur tenace
[Applaudissements]
et encore madame de fontenay
l'impression que la sorte de table
si si c'est vrai alors pour pour perdre
bien pour bien compris elle faisait du
que bientôt jordan il arrive à lui donc
ça il ya des masques ou pas c'est pareil
face et on vient me dire qu'on s'en fout
des choses que je disais merci beaucoup
angers on va donc revenir sur le sujet à
savoir 2 pts et mark on va revoir
l'élection qui a été remise en cause par
madame de fontenay alors c'était en 1987
c'est vrai que
s'est présentée par un certain guy lux
qui était le pendant de
la lazio faire pour tous il ya quelques
années un énorme cafouillage regarder
telle à la réunion avec joël ramia
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous êtes sûrs de notre
emplacement le ou est ce que nous en
sommes attendez oh là là ça y est nous y
sommes à kehl à petra vous êtes en train
de nous mettre mon chien écoute et qui
est classée troisième
c'est la camaro pitié donc deuxième
dauphine camargue et non pas réunion
c'est bien cela c'est ça tout à fait
bravo merci pour nous avoir fait des
émotions et j'avais cru que nous allions
avoir une émeute ici
c'était vraiment un joyeux bordel un
volume et donc voici d'élections au
final de nathalie marquay regarder et
donc par conséquent élue miss france
avec 42% points 2 des voix nathalie
marquay sur l'alsace
collection houleuse mais j'espère que ce
n'est pas très gentil ici dans un
mirifique parce que je trouve qu à vis
alsace et amusante nice alsace miss
france
alors nous en vidéo il ya nathalie
marquay nathalie bonsoir
ça va bien voire très bien bisous à tout
le monde mais dites-moi nathalie c'est
quoi ce contentieux avec les malades de
fonte et ça ça ça n'arrête plus
ment pas 35 presque 35 ans après
remettre ça sur le couvert c'est du
n'importe quoi en plus ce que je sais
c'est que
comment dire j'ai été élu à 42,2 % des
voix ça fait évident sur les dix
candidates c'est clair que pour moi miss
réunion à mes yeux c'était la plus jolie
la chance que moi j'ai eu c'est que je
faisais que la chance que j'ai eue c'est
que je représentais miss alsace donc
j'ai les alsaciens qui était très très
chauvins et qui moi qui ont donné
beaucoup de leur voix la réunion elle
n'avait pas beaucoup de chance parce
qu'à la réunion il y avait trois heures
de décalage horaire et déjà trois heures
du matin pour chez eux dont elle n'avait
pas de chance là dessus donc bah oui
c'est moi qui ai gagné mon titre je n'y
peux rien dans ce cas là alors ça veut
dire qu'à me demande je n'ai pas eu mon
titre aussi parce que j'ai quand même
été 6e dauphine à miss monde que ça a
été truquée alors je pense qu'on peut
peut-être sauver les archives qu'est ce
que vous répondez à madame de fontenay
chicago tape dessus nous basse et depuis
2005 depuis 2005 où c'est une guerre
entre nous puisque celle qui a démarré
en me disant que je faisais culbuteurs
faisant la ferme célébrités elle m'a dit
que je me faisais culbuter dans les
bottes de paille donc là c'est lui que
j'ai vu rouge c'est pas bien mal me font
pas c'est pas bien
donc c'est vrai que
là c'est de là que ça a démarré et puis
si ça s'est enchaîné et puis moi une
fois qu'on fait du mal c'est terminé bon
c'est clair que ça me fait mal au coeur
pour pour elle parce que je pense qu
elle va pas du tout bien il faudrait
qu'elle se fasse ont entouré de bonnes
personnes qu'elle pense à elle je suis
pas qu'elle aille faire des soins que je
sais pas mais c'est vrai que ça va pas
du tout ça me fait mal au coeur forêt et
en scène foot mais non j'ai eu de la
pitié pour elle ah bah oui bon on
comprend alors on va revoir un petit peu
les propos qu'elle avait tenus sur pato
tpm paix et on a parlé juste après en
sont très j'ai l'impression qu'il a
qu'il a épousée surtout son écharpe 1
parce qu'ils envoient entendu comme
d'autres jours c'est pas possible qu'il
soit à son niveau parce que quand même
c'est vrai qu'elle est là il arrive dans
une maison magnifique et d'argent et
tout ça sans avenir à et assurer un bon
réguler ces écharpes sans écharpe ne
serait pas là alors ça c'est extrêmement
méchant
c'est énorme moi ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que jean pierre mas elle dit
aussi que jean pierre mas et posée par
rapport à mon écharpe je pense que c'est
pas pour mon écharpe mais plutôt pour
mon cul qui m'ont répondu jean-pierre
ya 14 ans ça faisait longtemps que
j'étais plus miss france parce que ça
faisait quatre cités carte quatorze ans
après donc franchement elle dit
n'importe quoi
je sais pas cessé donne tout ce qu'elle
peut sortir je sais qu'elle s'en
prennent régulièrement uniquement à vous
alors depuis 2004 c'est oui
à lui faire passer à geneviève lâche-moi
la grappe ou à quoi
m'acheter pas ce soit la muse et housses
peut-être ça lui fait du bien de parce
que c'est vrai que dans son entourage ça
va pas très fort et qu'elle a besoin de
taper sur quelqu'un pour pour se venger
pour pour caen se libérer pour être bien
dans sa tête je comprends pas même
jean-pierre il est vraiment étonné aussi
en a ras-le-bol d'une ras-le-bol de
toutes ces histoires mais bon c'est
madame de fontenay qu'il faut dire on
est quoi emmener quoi le 15 septembre
francis france et voilà
abbas en salle a besoin elle a besoin
d'eux on parle d'années chaque année au
mois de septembre c'est rebelote parties
à trouver un petit message à passer à
edf qui change c'est sûr nous regarde
c'est triste mais vous me faites pitié
madame de fontenay donc je comprends pas
on s'est tellement aimé et d'ailleurs
j'ai écrit un ouvrage la wii je le dis
aussi que j'ai un pois chiche mais pour
une 15e fois çi j'ai pas aimé cry 4
ouvrages dont il sort demain j'ai écrit
deux pièces de théâtre qui ont fait un
carton une cage qui a été joué pendant
deux ans et l'autre était joué pendant
sept ans donc pour le pois chiche on en
reparlera plus tard et puis en plus elle
disait toujours à essayer de faire le
dicton de soi pas bête sois belle et
tais toi et elle essaie d'enlever sa
miss france parce que souvent c'est vrai
qu'à l'époque on disait qu'une miss
france a été belle et ça les castraises
elle se battait pour le contraire est
elle la lddhi maintenant que vais-je à
pois chiches ici la dette mais bon tout
ça c'est pas grave je ne lui en veux
plus j'ai autre chose j'ai une vie j'ai
mes enfants j'ai mon travail voilà
exactement
je vous embrasse mal de chantenay
s'adapter de chez
madame de fontenay a ouvert une petite
brèche en signifiant qu'ils avaient une
tromperie on a la preuve matérielle oui
qu'il n'y a absolument pas eu ni
tricherie ni tromperie il ya eu juste
quelqu'un au standard d'europe 1 qui ces
milliers d'emplois qui a confondu les
dauphines c'est la première fois c'était
en direct à la télé donc avec fr3 et
europe 1 europe 1 il ya eu beaucoup de
confusion celui qui compte
j'ai eu le procès verbal déposée de
l'élection et on voit les votes miss
alsace donc 8240 union 7080 et ça c'est
certifié j'ai eu tout le décompte donc
nathalie marquay n'a absolument pas
usurpé son titre la réunion a protesté
mais ça n'a pas de valeur
il y avait quand même une plainte de la
réunion l'époque pour raciste parce que
il ya une section en dessous ils ont
considéré qu'il avait été discriminée
mais le pq est formel et geneviève de
fontenay là dessus aujourd'hui dit
n'importe quoi nathalie marquay mérite
son titre de miss france 87 voilà c'est
dit c'est fait merci j
85e 7000 appels j'ai passé une heure du
matin c'est très
bien qu'il était sur la voyance bah oui
merci beaucoup de l'année on va bientôt
leur premier jeu
de fond des forêts étaient m'attendant
bd d'année marquée on va avancer avec le
sujet sur nabila hier soir y avait un
documentaire sur tmc c'est ce qu'on aime
c'est story sur l'habitat et on a
découvert
l'immense fortune le nabila je ne sais
pas si vous faites des petits postes
instagram mais moi je peux vous le dire
je vais m'y mettre parce que on peut
gagner beaucoup beaucoup à diou d'argent
pardon
si pour beaucoup d'habitants restent
simplement une starlette de la
téléréalité la plus jeune génération
c'est qu'en quelques années elle a
réussi le pari de devenir une femme
puissante de le monde de l'affluence tu
es dans ta jalousie je suis dans mon
jacuzzi krabi fasciné pas paradis ces
actions déchaîne les passions et ses
placements de produits lui rapporte des
millions chf riches si à la télé elle a
régulièrement signer des contrats autour
de quatre cent mille euros pour
participer à des émissions de télévision
amazon lui a proposé un million d'euros
pour la présentation de love island
mais incontestablement ce qui fait
appartenir nabila auxerre très
privilégié des millionnaires ce sont ces
placements de produits sur les réseaux
sociaux et vente flash qui sont
actuellement sur le site selon le
magazine voici la star toucherait chaque
mois pas moins de quatre cent mille
euros soit environ 4 8 millions d'euros
par an contrairement à nous on ne peut
pas dire qu'elle perd son temps sur
instagram
[Musique]
alors les chiffres sont astronomiques
petit bémol le programmé hier soir n'a
pas fonctionné et non seulement y a pas
fonctionné mais je n'ai généralement
avant quand il y avait on parlait de
nabila sur les réseaux s'était tout de
suite en top tweets et hier ça a été le
calme plat oui parce que c'est un peu
lui très jeune en tout cas j'ai enquêté
sur les chiffres ils sont exacts nabila
400000 euros par mois le couple nabila
est thomas 650000 euros par mois et ça
c'est uniquement les placements de
produits ce cas là aussi une marque de
beauté à la sonde il avec amazon en plus
et pour info les influences world iv
télé réalité issue date et l'heure était
à la réputation d' accepter tout et
n'importe quoi pour faire de l'argent il
refuse plein de contrastes art qui
choisissent les marques par me anne
marque de sextoys qui les a contactés
récemment ils ont refusé donc ils
prennent pas tous les contrats ils sont
hyper sélectifs et avec ça ils
réussissent à gagner beaucoup d'argent
donc franchement bravo guillaume tu dis
une bêtise parce que je crois que thomas
ne fait plus de placement de produit
c'est interdit de poster sur instagram
ya un chien qui l'ont fait sur les
réseaux sociaux soit ils se croient
qu'ils sont déportés marne sur tic toc
c'est ça ouais tik tok snapshot si son
style sont surtout les réseaux ils sont
très puissants franchement ça c'est un
modèle de réussite un nouveau modèle
mais franchement je suis conquis mousse
guillaume là donc ça la fin du marché
qu'on compte les bouses sur cinq six ans
à ce juge mois sa décision à 4000 euros
par mois sans barbe alors elle a touché
2 millions pour un truc d'amazon alors
amazonie avec vous je lève de table et
thaïlande il ya un million des clauses
éviter en plus ça fait 2 millions comme
1,2 million dont 2,2 millions d'euros
c'est un outil du deuil
fait toujours marrer quand on débat de
l'argent de l'argent tant mieux pour
elle après c'est une belle réussite
parce qu'au départ on habille la voix la
butte en france
pourrait payer des enfants en france
évidemment tels des enfants ça se fait
cambrioler excusez-moi médias que les
bleus risquent habitants frontale est
parfois bon l'aurait talent et lagardère
tombant d'accord mais les lakers
c'est à 400 me leroy l'a quand même y
avoir un truc sécurisé c'est quand même
pas le rebelle de démocratie non plus
encore quand même particulier pas de
s'installer là bas là c'est vrai que on
va dire que c'est voilà on peut on peut
critiquer
attend d elle elle gagne pas lll fait
pas c'est pas son argent en france en
faisant des concerts à bercy ou ou son
territoire a fait des postes les potes
c'est mondiale guillaume on est d'accord
elle pose sur le monde entier mais qui
la suit les
mois elle pose pas pour des marnes
habite à dubaï pour l'instant elle est
en train de déjouer un système fait
fiscale ou fiscaux je fais fiscale là
d'accord fiscal des fiscaux voilà assise
elle veut déjouer ça d'accord pour moi
ça me dérange pas car est à dubaï le
truc c'est khadra sera pas dubaï elle va
revenir en france et même impasse du
temps france c'est ça que je rejoins
steevy c'est dérangeant parce que elle
va se servir du système français quand
ce sera l'éducation quand ce sera la
santé est la maladie la session mais
cabaye la moine d'orange et du ballon
mais elle est très bien à dubaï toile
justement on suppute combien je gagne
parce que m c'est assez opaque et on
vous explique dans le dock pourquoi
notamment fiscalement il ya quelques
quelques virages frank était si nabila
benatia a choisi de domicilier sa
société dans ce tout petit état
américain à plus de onze mille
kilomètres de dubaï
ce n'est pas par amour des voyages en
avion il y a une vraie bonne raison
c'est un paradis fiscal il ya une petite
spécificité en plus de payer quasiment
pas d'impôt c'est qu'il ya aucune
transparence ya aucune obligation de
transparence non se gagnent la villa
grâce à sa marque de cosmétiques déjà
bon c'est que ça ne rapporte rien à
l'état français puisque ce ne sera pas
imposée en france même si elle de tout
ce sont 10 à dubaï mais il n'y a aucune
transparence ne peut pas savoir ce
qu'elle gagne probablement pas mal
d'argent
parce que vous dire sérieusement elle a
refusé deux propositions au cinéma ah
oui quand-même mouais écoutez bois du
cazier par personne n'a quitté que moi
je vous dis des gens qui réussissent
tant mieux pour eux mais voilà chacun
fait sa vie et elle mène bien sa barque